[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Галичина
Івано-Франківськ]
Двері, символічно,  — це вхід у будинок,
одна з найбільших архітектурних домінант.
І кожна людина, яка заходить у будинок,
торкається саме дверей.
Двері стали таким маячком,
який тепер теж надихає містян:
«Давайте, і тут щось спробуємо,
у дворі порядок наведемо».
[Марія Козакевич
Громадська активістка]
Це щось таке важливіше,
що може тебе внутрішньо гріти.
Навіть якщо усі навколо
не будуть знати, що ти там
стоїш біля цих дверей,
вони не знають, хто намагався їх врятувати.
Але тобі кайфово.
Ми не просто реставруємо двері,
ми намагаємось реставрувати
історичну пам'ять містян.
Насправді зі звичайного захоплення архітектурою...
Як би банально це не звучало:
гуляли багато з дітьми містом,
я з цікавості заглядала в під'їзди,
і воно мене з одного боку захоплювало,
подобалося — всі ці скляні ліхтарі,
плитка красива з візерунками, двері, вікна.
А з іншого боку я просто жахалася того, в якому стані воно все знаходиться.
І цей от контраст такого красивого...
Я часто називаю такі фотографії
«красуня і чудовисько».
Коли ця розкіш, занедбаність і людська байдужість.
Коли там красиві гвинтові сходи,
а поріч стоять два мішки сміття,
залишені мешканцями.
Вони і надихнули.
Я почала просто про це писати.
Створили групу в фейсбуці, з'явилась назва «Франківськ який треба берегти».
І з часом я зрозуміла, що мало про це писати і говорити —
потрібно робити якісь практичні кроки.
Кожні двері мають свою різну історію.
Якщо говорити про ці, то на них дуже добре видно
принцип правдивої реставрації.
Дуже часто, коли реставратори реставрують картину або старовинну ікону,
вони завжди те місце, яке втрачене,
малюють на декілька відтінків
світлішою фарбою.
Для того, щоб людина розуміла,
що це дійсно автентичне щось і старе,
а це от реставратор вже попрацював.
Вставка ось ця, тут дуже добре видно,
ось тут також зріз.
Ця новіша, вона прогнила була, чи трухлява, ми її замінили.
А це стара.
Так само видно ці потертості, вм'ятини,
ми всі їх завжди залишаємо.
Тому що ти до них доторкаєшся і вже відчуваєш атмосферу старого дерева.
Теж тут була така цікава історія: не було решіток.
Не було решіток, не було архівів, ми не знали взагалі,
як вони автентично виглядали і як їх нам відновити.
І ми подумали, придивились...
Якщо звернете увагу,
тут є такий кований паркан.
Ми ось цю форму на паркані
перенесли на ковану решітку.
Таким чином вийшли зі становища.
Традиційно ми на кожних дверях ставимо такі ковані таблички «Франківськ який треба берегти».
На кожних дверях польської чи австрійської доби
теж є такі маленькі
інвентаризаційні металеві таблички.
Ми подумали, чому б теж не зробити табличку
і показати, що ці двері були врятовані колись.
Найбільше, напевно,
і найважливіше завдання —
це не просто ініціативою врятувати всі двері.
Найбільше завдання —
це щоб самі містяни активізувалися
і почали дбати про свої будинки.
Наступні двері були першими
металевими дверима, за які ми взялися,
коли ми вже познайомилися з ковалями.
Вони були просто в жахливому стані.
Ці ручки були наполовину
обрізані, обірвані,
а вони дуже класні — в формі листочків.
Їх нам теж довелося відновлювати.
З рідних листків
залишилась тільки одна пара,
і одна чи дві пари на віконечку.
Тобто більшість з них —
це точна копія автентичних.
Ця вся нижня частина...
Як бачите, тут є такі шви.
Видно, що воно тут все міняли.
Бо просто воно «світилося» раніше.
От як лікарі ставлять діагноз,
коли розтин роблять пацієнту —
ми, як реставратори, можемо
поставити діагноз дверям,
коли знімаємо з них фарбу.
Зокрема, ці двері для нас були сюрпризом,
бо коли зняли фарбу, виявилось,
що на них є дуже цікаві латунні вставки.
Які раніше були замальовані,
або вирізані шукачами кольорових металів.
Взагалі, у нас дуже велика проблема з архівами.
Ось часто якихось деталей не вистачає,
найчастіше це буває скло.
Воно досить крихке, і найперше, що нищиться і не зберігається — це саме скло.
Ціла наша команда столярів,
ковалів, майстрів по вітражах,
по ліпнині, архітекторів,
краєзнавців, археологів —
це просто люди, які близькі за цінностями,
яким не треба пояснювати, для чого ми це все робимо і чому ми цим всім займаємося.
Зараз підходимо до дитячої бібліотеки.
Тут ми мали два проекти.
Перший з них — це двері.
Були рідні двері, а поставили пластикові.
Рідні не викинули і таким чином ми їх теж відреставрували,
повернули на місце вже в такому вигляді.
Це, як для мене, принципове питання.
Тому що коли діти йдуть в бібліотеку і
черпають знання,
то хочеться, щоб вони через щось справжнє заходили в цю бібліотеку.
Другий наш проект — це казкова вежа.
Якщо подивитися на неї, то одразу уявляєш собі якусь принцесу, яка сидить у віконечку.
Спустилась в неї довга коса, а внизу — принц.
Коли ми відреставрували двері, напросилися
в директорки піднятися у вежу,
бо вона була зачинена,
туди нікого не пускали.
І ми там, підсвічуючи ліхтариками від телефонів, знайшли три старовинні рами деев'яні.
І от ми тішилися дуже, взяли одразу ці рами, понесли в майстерню і вирішили їх відреставрувати.
Всі решта вікон нові,
бо абсолютно були втрачені.
Деякі віконні скельця
мають форму ромба.
Так само чимось нагадує, як на даху, ця бляха такими ромбиками викладена.
Ми так само взяли для вітражів.
Взагалі, процес реставрації чимось нагадує театральне дійство, п'єсу.
[Валеріан Федоряк
Майстер по вітражам]
Тобто вся ця фарба, яка все закриває і нічого не видно, коли ми знімаємо —
це ніби починається перший акт
і на сцені розходяться.
І ми бачимо, що там всередині.
Перший акт щойно почався —
Ростислав відколупав шматок фарби,
а там дуже цікавий декоративний елемент.
І от йде оцей акт перший, акт другий,
і коли цей готовий виріб монтується назад,
вставляється на місце, де він стояв,
і ще не одну сотню років простоїть — аплодисменти.
Найгірше, що це не цінується, що воно так,
десь люди кажуть, що це сміття.
[Ростислав Хабурський
Столяр]
Ви бачили вже сьогодні,
що можна з них зробити,
що це дійсно може бути окрасою.
Тут можна просто подивитись цей принцип,
за яким воно замальовано,
оскільки вона товстими шматками
відлітає, ця фарба.
Скільки тут шарів і як вона виглядає, ця фрамуга.
Наскільки воно запилючене, з брудом, з усім.
А в майстерні вже можна побачити,
коли фарба знята, після реставрації —
яка величезна різниця.
Складні двері, насправді, поки в роботі — дуже добре видно,
коли нові елементи, наскільки
це все ажурна робота і дуже тонка.
Потрібно дуже-дуже скурпульозно до цього відноситись.
От видно яка велика різниця, коли зняли фарбу.
Наскільки красива фактура самого дерева —
дубові двері.
Дуже надійна річ, яка прослужить ще
десятиліття і століття.
Отут кованої решітки не було,
тут було лише засклення.
Ми зараз думаємо, яке саме тут поставити скло
і як його грамотно обіграти.
Тому що дуже важливо не переборщити,
ту гармонію, яка вже є у столярній роботі —
не перекричати її склом,
якось акуратно і грамотно продумати,
як би воно мало виглядати.
Хтось міг би сказати, що це вже все,
що цим дверям уже час на відпочинок.
Давайте пластикові поставимо,
вони будуть стояти ще довго.
Ми жартуємо, що у нас двері,
коли потрапляють на реставрацію,
то це як таке своєрідне санаторно-курортне лікування у них.
Важливо, що дійсно, всі ми зі схожими цінностями,
з відповідальним ставленням до цієї роботи.
Ми розуміємо, що ми не просто двері реставруємо,
ми справді вносимо виховний момент
в розвиток міста.
Справді пропагуємо ту любов до міста.
Так ця синергія дає класні,
позитивні результати.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Макс Завалля]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажери
Роман Липак, Оля Черник]
[Музика
Omodada Gee, Sasha Boole, TeЯРеМ]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]